vladimir putin le dijo a su ministro de
defensa que se abstuviera de atacar la
planta de acero a s'hostal en mariupol
último bastión de resistencia en el
puerto del mar azov los rusos parecían
previamente decididos a tomar hasta el
último centímetro de la ciudad
consideró innecesario el asalto
propuesto a la planta siderúrgica le
ordenó que lo cancele este es un caso en
el que debemos pensar quiero decir que
siempre debemos pensar pero en este caso
más en preservar la vida y la salud de
nuestros soldados y oficiales de 60
la vice primera ministra de ucrania ha
pedido a los militares rusos que abran
un corredor humanitario desde la planta
siderúrgica hay alrededor de 1000
civiles y unos 500 soldados heridos
todos necesitan ser sacados diasoft al
hoy
la captura de us hostal un sitio de 10
kilómetros cuadrados permitiría a rusia
decir que tiene el control total de
mariupol
las autoridades ucranianas publicaron
estas imágenes de familias en refugios
subterráneos en la planta estos
residentes de mariupol que viven cerca
de los combates dan cuenta de que la
situación es increíblemente peligrosa
es aterrador todos estamos asustados
sólo los idiotas no tendrían miedo
la batalla por mariupol ha sido
devastadora se cree que más de 100.000
personas siguen atrapadas allí con poca
comida agua y medicinas